okay how would I describe without like
using super arty pretentious her it's a
very poignant very interesting show
about two things about you know the the
60s and how that changed American
culture you may act like he wants a
secretary but most of the time they're
looking for something between a mother
and a waitress but also about a bunch of
characters who realize they have
something lacking in them and they're
trying to fill that nostalgia it's
delicate but potent so Matt Winer you
can tell that he is there every step of
boy because this show is always so
exacting we produced if I had it in my
head we would do everything we could to
get it exactly as I pictured it
one of the most elaborate being done on
that set with when he gives Megan the
job in the commercial I saw in my head
that he would walk towards the camera
and the set would be this little jewel
in the background for you only live
twice and I knew that was the song it
was playing
artistically it's the idea that you
don't have to say everything like
everything can remain subtext tell me
somebody what happened on Mad Men you
know that's like a sense how it happened
is the part that people are like no you
don't understand
heat said I know who you are I know that
your name is not Donald Draper and
that's all it happened right and then
Cooper said who cares mr. Campbell who
cares that's not what it's like watching
that episode you have a knot in your
stomach and it's 15 minutes Peggy I'm
glad that this is an environment where
you feel free to fail Don and Peggy's
relationship to me is one of the best
things about the show and most
fascinating things about the show and I
think it's because it's not romantic
even though it could be romantic
you never say thank you for instead they
saw something in each other and Don saw
something in Peggy that they didn't want
to take her on a sort of his mentee it
all culminates in this episode the
suitcase what's the most exciting thing
about a suitcase
going somewhere it's really beautiful
and well thought out she's all of these
different figures to Don and they're
sort of comforting each other and also
at odds it's it's fantastic television I
think if one episode of this show
survives to out the time capsule will be
that one
I think Mad Men takes us to a place in
time where we want to go like I think
there is that escapist element on it
even if the show is not depicting the
60s as this age of glitz and glamour
it's a show that's about a world that's
not so far removed from our own but is
just far enough removed from our own
that we can sort of look at our own
world through its skewed lens
you